hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from a match that pretty much
just started it's the 2021 Challengers
Chester Champion pragnananda versus the
2022 Challengers Chester champion pranav
and the two of them are gonna brawl it
out for ten thousand dollars uh the
match will be played in Tel Aviv and
it's gonna be uh four series of mini
matches two series of rapid and the two
series of Blitz and this is the first
decisive game that took place from the
rapid section so let's check it out it's
quite a nice one I'm sure you guys are
are going to enjoy it uh let's dive
straight into it yeah so Prana with the
white pieces opens with Pawn to E4 we
have Pawn to E5 by Prague Knight to F3
Knight to C6 and now Bishop to B5 Duru
Lopez is on the board with A6 progos for
morphe's defense the shop to A4 and now
Bishop to C5 as this is very very uh
popular nowadays with C3 and now Knight
G37 B5 still the more popular move but
Knight gt7 E7 also the second most
popular so nothing weird happening here
D4 striking in the center E Capture C
captress and Bishop to B4 width check
Bishop to D2 and we have captors
captures Knight B captures on D2 and
pawn to D5 now now all been played
before but the moves that are known here
are Ponte E5 and there is uh one only
one game where H3 was played uh but here
we have uh castles by pranav and it is
now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so let's see how the
game continues D captures an E4 we have
Knight captures on e4 and here Prague
castles H3 stopping Bishop to G4 and now
Bishop to F5 we have Rook D1 defending
the Knight and the pawn to H6 taking
away that G5 Square from White's pieces
uh Rook the C1 and now Bishop captures
on e4 now okay this is uh giving up your
your Bishop maybe a bit too soon but
it's uh hard to say what what to
actually play here maybe to bring the
knights to G6 but then you can't move
the bishop maybe you're gonna go B5
first uh but Prague wants to play Queen
to D6 and for that he needs to eliminate
it this Knight so Bishop captures uh an
E4 Rook captures and queen to D6 Now
product develops the queen connects the
Rooks and also uh this is a rapid uh so
the players uh have uh uh 10 minutes for
the entire game plus there's a five
second increment uh starting from move
one with A3 uh Rook 8 to d8 and now
Queen to C2 so now if anything uh moves
out of that C file you can always
capture that pawn on C7 uh Queen to F6
now and Rook C the E1 uh here pranav
doubles up on the E file Rook to D6 by
prog now getting ready to double up on
the D file and now Knight to E5 and here
already complications are starting to
get a bit serious because if you capture
on D4 here let's say Knight captures on
D4 and queen captures on C7 seems like
okay it's perfectly fine for black but
uh black is dead lost here like there's
nothing you can play you can try some
like B5 you attack the bishop uh this
Knight the G4 move is uh so deadly you
attack the queen there is now a triple
attack on the Knight on E7 let's say
queen G6 you're gonna capture an E7 and
okay black will win back the piece but
now 95 and now okay you're attacking the
F 7.3 times the queen is overloaded you
cannot defend F7 and The Rook here you
can try some like Queen F6 but not
Knight D7 connects nicely here Forks the
queen and the rook and black loses a lot
of material ended the game so after
Knight the E5 we have B5 by Prague
chasing away the bishop Bishop back to
B3 and now Rook captures on D4 by Prague
and again uh what do you play here this
is a very very complicated that if you
go for Knight captures on C6 then just
throw captures on e4 and no problem
there Queen captures any fortnite
captures on C6 and everything is nicely
defended probably is even a pawn up so
uh what you have to play here and the
what wasn't played in the game is in
fact Knight captures on F7 here if Prana
found this uh he would uh definitely uh
have an advantage in the position the
problem is you cannot capture the Knight
defro captures on F7 then look at this
Rook to E6 the only winning move so
that's why it's probably uh so difficult
to spot attacks the queen and now
attacks the Knight twice here and once
you move the queen uh Rook characters on
C6 and knife Knight captures and C6 just
Rook to E8 or any other line it's
completely winning for white but a very
hard to spot you would however have
after Knight captures and F7 this Rook
captures an E4 idea but still Knight the
G5 opens up a discovery you will connect
with the Rook nicely and after King day
trade Knight captures on e4 and okay the
game continues but the white will always
be a little bit better so that was
definitely in the position so not uh
winning by force but pranaf could have
uh taken the up the upper hand here but
he went Knight to G4 right away and now
probably just plays Queen to G5 we have
Rook captures on D4 and now Knight
capture Sandy for attacks the queen and
the bishop Queen captures on C7 and now
Knight to G6 uh and how do you continue
here uh again very difficult the bishop
to A2 was played the bishop is hanging
here but you should play Queen back to
C3 or even better Bishop to D1 or it's
hard to say what's better but after
Bishop to A2 uh there's a there's a huge
hole in the position and Prague spots it
he plays Pawn to H5 and now you cannot
move the Knight if you move the Knight
the Knight to F3 check the G Pawn is
pinned uh you will you will just uh lose
a lot of material here so after H5 Queen
to C3 was played which makes sense okay
you capture the Knight on G4 I'm gonna
capture on D4 uh the problem is uh Rook
the d8 defends the Knight and the the
Knight on G4 is still hanging so here
Rook to E4 uh attacking again the Knight
on D4 but now comes in Knights the F4
and uh again uh it's so complicated that
even Prague missed the idea here because
he has to play h capital San G4 point is
that after Rook captures on D4 Rook
capture Sunday for Queen captures uh G
captures and H3 now threatens Checkmate
and it's a very very hard to defend you
will have to play G3 then the Knight
comes the E5 the F3 uh becomes
incredibly weak and black will not be
able to withstand this uh but okay uh
it's a rapid game like I said Knight to
F4 was played and this makes it uh old
the more complicated uh because now look
at all of these Knights the E2 checks
forking the king and the queen
everything is just hanging here like if
you move the real Pro captures on D4
immediately Knights the to Chuck wins
the queen on C3 so instead after Knight
to F4 Queen the E3 was played a king to
H2 is the only move here but who plays
King to each during a rapid game uh so
Queen to E3 was played and now look at
this age captures on G4 proxies alright
thank you for the piece and now again
you cannot capture here because that E2
uh Square will always be hanging just
Rook characters on D4 and you cannot
recapture again you will blunder so
after H Captain G4 Bishop captures an F7
with check King the H7 and now uh the
problem is and this is probably the one
that pranav missed if you play Rook
captures on F4 now then there's Queen
captures on F4 like all of the all of
the forks just working Black's favor
Queen captures on f490 to check King
wherever and now just Knight captures on
F4 will be Checkmate so after King stage
seven King the HD was played a few moves
too late because in that the position a
few moves ago the king H2 was the
absolute strongest move to play so feel
free to pause the video now and try to
find the forced mate in 9 for Prague
while I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
brilliancy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Knight to
F3 with check this is what proc played
and only one more move was played
because uh you can't go to G1 if you go
to H1 then Rook to D1 check and if you
go to G3 then look at this Knight stage
five check Bishop captures on H5 only
move Queen to H for check King to F4 and
now Rook to f8 with check you have to
block with the bishop and this will now
be Checkmate so after Knight to F3 G
captures on F3 was played and here
probably just played G captures on H3
and it was in this position unmove 30
that Prana resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here even though
the Knight on F4 is still uh hanging
there is no move that the defense Queen
to G2 Checkmate there is absolutely
nothing you can do here there you can
give some silly checks here to maybe
prolong the game a little bit but of
course these gentlemen do not play Such
moves
uh so yeah uh that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it uh pranav had a a better
position and he could have taken the
upper hand if he spotted that Bishop
captures an F7 move but not in this
position uh in the position uh that we
discussed a bit earlier uh here after
this uh uh Rook captures on G4 uh here
Knight captures and F7 should have been
played not Bishop captures on F7 uh but
yeah here if you found this then he
would have a great game but he missed
this one little detail and then uh it
was pretty much a Prague for the rest of
the game uh so yeah once again I hope
you guys uh hope you guys enjoyed it
really a wild one uh if uh another
interesting game arises from this
competition I will definitely cover it
and if you spot one also do use hashtag
suggestion always use hashtag suggestion
uh as that makes uh it a lot easier for
me to spot incredible games for us to
enjoy uh so yeah once again hope you
enjoyed it I would like to wish a very
happy birthday terretto hope you had a a
good one and that you will win many
great games and I would like to thank
Croatia and Nikola German the Hagler and
the PG mastering for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day